we're going to leave jeffrey donaldson
in belfast because uh rishi sooneck the
chancellor is about to hold a news
conference
about what's happening to your energy
bills and what the government is going
to do to help
following ofgem's decision today to
increase the energy price cap i know
that many of you are feeling anxious
but i want to reassure you
the plans i set out in parliament today
are going to help you
and your family
now anyone who tells you there's an easy
answer to this situation is not being
straight with you
the reasons prices are rising are global
a difficult winter last year depleted
global gas stores there's been
disruption to other energy sources like
nuclear and wind
and we've seen higher demand for gas in
asia
all those factors are outside of the
government's control
there is in truth nothing the british
government can do about a nuclear power
plant going offline in europe or a
factory in china deciding to produce
more goods
but what we can do
is take the sting out of the price shock
as we and the world adjust to higher
energy prices
without government action
today's increase in the price cap would
leave households needing to find on
average an extra
693 pounds this year
that is clearly
a very significant sum
so for the vast majority of families the
government is taking direct action to
share the burden
today we're announcing an energy bills
rebate worth
350 pounds
you'll receive that cash support through
two different routes
first
all electricity customers will receive
an upfront discount worth 200 pounds
that discount will then be automatically
repaid from people's bills over the next
five years in equal instalments of 40
pounds a year starting next april
this is the right way to support people
while continuing with our responsible
plans to reduce borrowing and debt
second
we will pay a council tax rebate of 150
pounds to all households in bands a to d
which covers around four out of every
five households in england
the reason for doing this through the
council tax system is because it's the
quickest way to get monies to the
families who most need it
if you're eligible the rebate will be
paid in april and it won't need to be
repaid
in total we're helping the vast majority
of families pay their energy bills with
350 pounds
our plan is right
it is fair
and i hope it will help ease the anxiety
that millions of people feel about
rising energy costs
by sharing the burden between us all
thank you
be very happy to take some questions and
i think first up we've got jonathan
from bbc jonathan hi
thank you chancellor and the support
you've announced today is aimed at
helping households this year but
industry experts expect high gas prices
to persist isn't the reality that higher
energy prices are here to stay and that
you will have to come back with further
support in the future if not are you
willing to rule that out at this point
and a follow-up if i may can i ask for
your reaction to the resignation of the
prime minister's head of policy manira
mirza and whether you agree with her
that he should apologize for his
comments to secure stamina about jimmy
several
thanks uh jonathan so taking a step back
about energy prices
as i mentioned the factors that are
driving higher gas prices are global in
nature and i i went through them in my
statement and i don't have a crystal
ball as to what exactly the future holds
but i want to be honest with people yeah
higher energy prices are something that
we're going to have to adjust to uh in
common with other countries around the
world and it would be wrong to pretend
otherwise but what we can do is slow
that adjustment to make it more
manageable for people's household
budgets and that's what our
interventions do your right energy bills
may go up again in october the rebate
that i announced today the 200 pounds
off all energy bills that will kick in
in october so it will actually help
with that but over time we'll have to
see what happens as i said this is
something that we're going to have to
get used to but the interventions today
will help that adjustment happen in in
better time
and with regard to the news about manira
first thing to say is you know she was a
valued colleague i very much enjoyed
working with her and i'm sorry to see
her leave government i'll miss working
with her
and with regard to the comments
and you know being being honest i
wouldn't have said it and i'm glad that
the prime minister clarified what he
meant
next robert where are you
hi very good to see you um
you've announced you're deploying
something like 9 billion pounds in total
everybody will be helped a bit
but they're still gonna be
a price rise of 350 quid at least
for everybody on average now you know
that it's the poorest
third of people
who are
hurt most by these energy price rises
why didn't you deploy that nine billion
and simply help the poorest
third if you believed in leveling up
surely that's what you would have done
and i do just want to quote a couple of
lines from manila mozart's resignation
letter she says she believes it was
wrong for the prime minister this week
uh to imply that kirsten was personally
responsible for allowing jimmy savile to
escape justice there was no fair or
reasonable basis for that assertion the
prime minister hasn't apologized he's
explained but he hasn't said sorry
surely he should say sorry
thanks uh robert so on on your
first question you know of course there
are choices that we we have to make when
we're designing a policy like this you
know my view was that the price rise is
so significant that it's not just those
families who are on benefits that are
going to feel the pinch is actually
middle-income families as well families
that are working hard they're not on
welfare but this will be a significant
increase for them and i wanted to make
sure that support we provided also went
to those families that's why we've
decided to go to bands a to d which is
four out of every five households in
england very deliberately to help those
families uh in the middle as well so
that's a deliberate choice but if you
look at what we're doing
because it's flat rate it's a flat 200
pounds and a flat 150 pounds that
obviously is going to mean more to a
family on lower incomes or with lower
energy bills so in that sense it is a
progressive measure that will help those
families more and we have various other
interventions that are also targeted at
exactly the the people that you rightly
highlight for example the warms homes
discount is a rebate that exists through
energy bills we've expanded that
eligibility we're in the process of
doing that by a third so that will then
cover three million of our most
vulnerable households that's a 150 pound
rebate we're also spending over the
course of this parliament about three
billion pounds specifically targeted on
the people
that you mentioned to help improve the
energy efficiency of their homes and
that's a sensible long-term thing to do
because even though it cost thousands of
pounds up front it will save those
people on average about 290 300 pounds a
year on their energy bills going forward
and of course by cutting the universal
credit taper rate by increasing the
national living wage both of those are
really significant interventions which
will put more money in the pockets of
those who are most vulnerable so i think
if you look at it in the round you know
i feel confident that we're getting help
to the people who need it in different
different ways and with regard to your
second question you know it's a question
for the prime minister rather than me
and there's probably not much more i can
add other than what i've already said
which i hope you appreciate uh next ed's
they are hi
and you talked a lot during the pandemic
about doing whatever it takes to try and
help families when they're going through
difficult times i'm just wondering given
given what you said about how difficult
this is going to be to confront are you
able to make the same commitment when it
comes to their energy bills whether it's
looking specifically their bills are
indeed looking at things like our net
zero policy and working out the way that
it feeds into this and just secondly you
know what's your message to people who
are looking at their bills they're
looking at what you're offering them and
they're saying this simply
isn't enough and now they're
contemplating a very difficult few
months ahead
i think the first thing to say is i
absolutely recognize this is a difficult
time right i know this is this is
probably the number one issue on most
families minds you know they're looking
at the news they're seeing prices go up
they're worried about the cost of living
in a particular energy and that's why
we're taking action and i really believe
that what we're doing 350 pounds it's a
significant amount of money that will
make a big difference to to the vast
majority of households and i think
people i hope actually will be reassured
by us stepping in to provide that
support to ease some of the adjustment
uh that this is um so you know when you
ask you know what's our approach and our
approach over the last year or two has
been to do the right things to support
people through difficult times to
support the economy when it needed it
and i think today's announcement
continues in that vein
and as in robert's question we're trying
to get the balance right and getting
support to the people who need it most
but i'm also being honest with everybody
you know i can't change global energy
prices uh your point about our
transition to net zero is a good one and
what we need to do is we've got to put
the right long-term energy policy in
place and for example we're investing in
new nuclear power that's something that
previous governments had had neglected
but we're fixing that the energy
secretary quasi quatern is brilliantly
getting on with that we announced money
for that in last year's spending review
we're also doing lots of offshore wind
where we're a leader those are sensible
things to do and lastly we probably have
you know i want to make sure that people
acknowledge that we should also exploit
our domestic resources and we have
resources in the north sea want to
encourage investment in that because
we're going to need natural gas as part
of our transition to getting to net zero
and in the process of getting from here
to there if we can get investment in the
north sea that supports british jobs
that's a good thing so that has to be
part of the mix as well
uh jason from the daily mail jason where
are you there you are hi
um
the bank of england says we're facing uh
the biggest squeeze on living standards
on record
um isn't this the time to think again
about that national insurance advisor
it's going to hit
average workers with an extra 250 pound
bill this year and on the kind of wider
political picture
the pm said sorry about some of the
parties that took place uh in this
street
um some of your mps and certainly the
public are still very angry with him you
i think are still supporting him what
why do you think what would you tell
people about why he should be given a
second chance
so jason on on the first question about
the health and social care levy uh you
know i i do believe this is the right
thing to do if you think you know what's
the country's number one priority when
it comes to public services it's the nhs
and we're faced with a situation where
the backlogs are growing to unacceptable
levels as a result of covid and i think
everyone wants to see action on that you
know we'll get to a point where almost
every family will have a family member
grandparent aunt uncle who's on a
waiting list and that that's something
that we didn't want to see happen and at
the same time i think we wanted to do
what other governments have not done and
the prime minister deserves credit for
this and that's grappling with the
challenges in fixing social care
both of those things are big challenges
to take on and they do require a serious
amount of funding now we wanted to do
the difficult decision i mean of course
it's a difficult decision to introduce a
new levy it's not something i would
wanted to have to do but confronted with
a once in 300 year economic shock to
deal with and taking on these two big
challenges i thought it was right as did
the prime minister in the government to
introduce a new levy to help fund the
people's number one priority not just
today but for years into the future and
i think people can be reassured that
every pound of that levy is going to go
on the thing they care most most about
which is the nhs and social care um and
the way we're doing it i believe is
progressive those with the broader
shoulders will bear the biggest burden
from it the top 15 percent of taxpayers
will will contribute around half of the
revenues from that and as i said it's
dedicated and specific so people will
know that all the money is going to the
thing that they care most about uh and
you know on your you know on your second
question again
this question for the prime minister i i
think he was right to uh do say what he
said in parliament just recently and
before he he's apologized for that he
said he's going to fix it he's
acknowledged some of the poor all of the
recommendations from sue grey's report
and you know you'll expect to hear more
from them as he said about the changes
that he's planning to make so and that's
why he has my support and i'm glad that
he's doing what he's doing
lucy from the telegraph hi hi uh lucy
fisher from telegraph uh chancellor when
you look at the levees on energy bills
the looming council tax rises the
increase in national insurance the
income tax threshold freezes and here
the bank of england governor warned
today that the public face the biggest
fall in living standards in at least 30
years is there a point as a conservative
chancellor that you step in and say
people are paying too much
tax well you know lucy you you're right
to list some of them or many of the
challenges that that people are facing
and i very much acknowledge that we we
are grappling with some of them families
are grappling with those challenges but
i think you can point to some things on
the other side of the ledger as well
that are going to make a difference
obviously the announcements today 350
pounds for the vast majority of families
i think is a significant amount and it
will make a difference to to people the
national living wage is going up by 6.6
in april to nine pounds fifty an hour
that's quite a significant increase it's
worth about a thousand pounds a year for
someone um earning the national living
wages millions of people do the
universal credit taper rate cut that we
announced last year which essentially is
a tax cut for those on the lowest
incomes again for a single mother who's
working full-time on the national living
wage that's worth about 1200 pounds
extra a year in their pocket so that
will help with frozen fuel duty and we
have as we've discussed with robert's
question lots of other schemes to help
people in need with energy costs so
you know i think look when i look at the
picture of course there are challenges
but there are things we were doing to
help people and jason's question earlier
we are making sure that we also address
the other thing that they care about
which is having an nhs that's
well-funded that can make sure they
don't wait years and years for the
treatment that they desperately want for
them and their families i think people
care about that as well
going forward i'll point you to what i
said at the budget in in autumn last
year you know my goal my mission over
the remainder of this parliament is to
cut people's taxes that's what i want to
deliver i think that's what the country
would like to see they appreciate i
would hope that we've been through i
said once in a 300-year economic shock
borrowing gone to the highest level
since world war ii and we do need to fix
that but we are well on our way to
rebuilding our economy if you look at
what's happening with people in work and
wages
business investment all of those signs
are really positive so there's lots that
we feel confident about i know that
there are some challenges ahead but
longer term i feel confident about being
able to deliver on
my pledge to reduce people's taxes and
we made a start of that by cutting taxes
for those on the lowest paid last autumn
and that is a sign of where we want to
go in the future as well
um
david from reuters
hi good evening uh good evening um
chancellor earlier today the bank of
england sort of raised interest rates
said that wasn't just to do with sort of
higher energy costs but also sort of
growing cost pressures and also sort of
wage pressures in the economy that some
businesses spoke to thought that wages
might need to go up by five percent of
this year and i know that sort of last
year you and the prime minister talked
about the need for a high wage economy
but in the short term is wage restraint
something that you would welcome in the
private sector i think that needs to be
in the public sector
david uh obviously monetary policy is
independent for the for the bank of
england so i'll leave i'll leave andrew
and the governor to to deal with that
with regard to wages it's not my job to
set wages in the private sector right um
and you know all i'd say is you know yes
of course i want
a high wage economy who doesn't the
right way to get there is to drive up
productivity right we want to make sure
that those wages are a reflection of the
fact that we are you know producing more
doing more and the best way to get that
productivity increase is to have
businesses invest and that's why we've
got interventions like the super
deduction which is a very generous tax
incentive for companies to invest and we
know companies are sitting on quite a
bit of cash and it'd be good for the
economy if we economy if we can unlock
that get them investing in that if you
look at all the surveys whether it's the
cbi deloitte ernst young all of them
point to business investment intentions
being electrically very high level so
that's a promising sign for driving up
growth and productivity if we can unlock
investment and then the other part of it
is by investing in people in their
skills and you know the spending review
last year we announced i think a three
and a half billion pound increase in the
amount of money that we spend on skills
it's a 26
real increase so it's almost
unprecedented for a parliament to spend
that much more on skills but it's really
important so if you're an adult who
doesn't have a level three qualification
for example it's equivalent of an a
level and there are about nine or ten
million adults in our country who don't
um you know for the first time actually
the government at any age that you are
will fully fund you to get one of those
qualifications that cost about three
thousand pounds but we know it will make
an enormous difference to your chance of
getting a job or for your in work
earning more as a result of those new
skills you require and that's just one
of the many things we're doing there's
traineeships apprenticeships
sector-based work academies skill boot
camps all of these things on new
interventions that will help people get
the skills they need to get higher
productivity higher wage jobs that's the
right long-term approach
for us to get there look at course it
doesn't happen overnight but i'm
confident we're doing all the right
things that put us on that path to to
getting there over time
thomas from business insider thomas
johnson um the plan to give energy
rebates to households in certain council
tax plans means 2.2 million of people on
lowest incomes won't automatically
benefit
um meanwhile many of those in the
highest household incomes will benefit
do you accept it's a
poorly targeted tax basing it on
property values from 30 years ago um and
secondly just to follow up would you
welcome a full apology from the prime
minister um regarding his comments uh to
kirsten earlier this week
so thompson your second question i
haven't got anything to add to what i've
said to the the previous answers but on
your on your first question i probably
don't i don't accept that look there's
no perfect way uh when you design policy
that has to work on this scale for it to
be perfectly targeted right so there's
no way to perfectly do it i can't sit
here and figure out the individual
circumstances of all 28 million
households that we're trying to get
support to um so i accept that nothing
is is perfect but uh to your point
specifically about lower income
households who who happen to live in
higher council tax bans that is a
reasonable question and we have looked
at that specifically and that's why
we've created a discretionary fund of
about 150 million pounds that will be
given to local authorities specifically
to help exactly those people now by our
estimates they're around 300 000 people
actually so for example who are on low
income or on benefits who happen to live
in in council tax bands higher than band
d
so we've we've actually given more than
the money needed for them so that
there's a bit of extra cushion so that
local authorities can find those people
and get them the support they need i
think that's very fair but we've made a
provision for that as i said through
this uh through this discretionary fund
and other than that i think the council
tax system is a good way to deliver
support it's the only other part of our
entire tax system that works on a
household basis and if you think about
it you pay energy bills as a household
so this is a way to think about people
as a household so that's sensible and
the other thing is it's quick right lots
of other things take a long time to
figure out uh for example the rebate you
know that will kick in in october
because it's time there's statutory
consultations and operational things to
work through the council tax system is
really fast councils do a brilliant job
for us the systems are set up so people
will feel that 150 pounds in april
and that's really good i think actually
and that's one of the benefits of using
that system uh to do that um and i think
i've got a bit of time to take a couple
more uh if i'm being uh not hurried out
um so i i don't know who we've got here
is natasha here or not natasha do you
have do you have a question there you
are all right
sorry to impress you on the monero
question do you think the prime minister
should say sorry for his comments do you
feel it would help to to
move on from the whole situation um can
i just ask you some of your colleagues
have said that you're uh you know uh
labor light and unconservative for your
um
raising taxes and giving people money to
pay the energy bills do you agree with
them
uh nitesh thanks look so on your first
question again i just have to repeat
what i've said before obviously that's
for the prime minister to decide but i'm
glad he he clarified what he meant
earlier today uh as i said i'll miss
i'll miss working with the manera to
your second question you know for me
being a conservative part of that is
about being responsible with people's
money and being responsible with the
public finances that's really important
to me i think that's people what people
expect quite frankly from a conservative
government for a conservative chancellor
i think they you know i hope that people
understand we were faced with a enormous
shock and that meant that borrowing
skyrocketed up to levels that we haven't
seen since world war ii and it's going
to take us a little bit of time to fix
that but fixing it is the right thing to
do it's the responsible thing to do it's
not always easy to do these difficult
things but as long as i have this job
i'm going to try and do what i believe
to be right in the long term interests
of the country and actually this energy
situation is a good example of why it's
important because i've made the case
previously to to to you and others
we need to have the resilience to
respond to future shocks and look if you
think in the last 10 years we've had two
supposedly once in a century events we
had the financial crisis you know which
robert spent every minute covering and
aired and others uh and then we had you
know obviously coronavirus uh they
happened in the space of a decade and i
was really fortunate that because my
predecessors had taken some difficult
decisions when they had this job i was
able to respond comprehensively and
generously to support the country
families businesses through that crisis
and and now again we're faced with
another thing with energy i want to
better respond and because we've taken
some difficult decisions already to to
get things in a better place i can do
that but i want whoever's in this job in
the future to hopefully have benefited
from the tough things that i did so that
they can support the country when the
time comes again and i think that is a
deeply conservative uh thing to do i
think we you know people understand we
have to live within our means i think
they get that they expect that from us
and that's what i will deliver as long
as i i i'm doing this
um george i had to tell you i had your
hand up
um you're seeing the analysts saying
that they think it's possible the energy
price cap could go up to as high as 2
400 pounds in october could you exclude
now the possibility you'll have to do
even more in the autumn to help families
and just a second again on monero merza
you said you enjoyed working with her
and i just wanted you to say what you
thought she brought to the government
right um so on on your on your first uh
question
you know as i said before you know
there's global forces at play here that
drive up uh gas prices at the moment and
i don't have a crystal ball you're right
the current energy markets are
forecasting that prices go up further in
october before falling quite
significantly next spring but again i
don't have a crystal ball and these
things uh
are uncertain i think the interventions
we've done today are designed to last uh
and provide support to people over the
year we're front loading it so the 150
pounds of the 350 comes all in one go at
the beginning but then
in october let's say the price cap does
go up again then that's when the 200
pounds rebate will also kick in at that
moment so there will be help at that
time if that is indeed uh what happened
so i think over the course of a year is
the best way to think about it there's
350 pounds of support for the vast
majority of families to help them over
the year with this um and again i would
go back to what i said i've got to be
honest i don't want to pretend that we
don't have to adjust to higher energy
prices you know if that that's what the
world is having to do but what we can do
is just slow the pace of that down make
it more manageable for people's um
household finances and i'm not going to
get into a big thing about manira you
know so you know she you know she's a
valued colleague she brought a lot to
the job and and i'll miss i'll miss
working with her
great um
yes
if i've got one more right go on yeah
uh simon neville from pa um
just uh
want to get my head around this um i'm
not gonna call it a bailout but i i
think some people call it have called it
that um energy firms were asking for a
similar package for quite a few months
we've known that the energy prices were
going to go up for quite some time um
back then uh it was rejected uh the
court i think 20 billion was the number
that was put on it by the firms um
what changed that meant now you decided
it was the right call to make
um and the other question i wanted to
ask was around national insurance um
you're giving households the opportunity
to delay their payments on their energy
bills
why not give them the opportunity to
delay their payments uh for national
insurance
so on um
i think in terms of the difference
they're two two very different things
right we're putting in place a new
dedicated health and social care levy uh
so that people can feel reassured that
every pound of that is going through the
thing that they care most about which is
the nhs and it means we can make a start
on tackling the backlogs as quickly as
possible and start reforming social care
i think that's the right thing to do the
responsible thing to do as of as of
outlined but where we can make a
difference on these energy prices we are
and part of the response is to smooth
the impact of that and that is a very
deliberate policy approach as it can't
pretend that we don't have to adjust to
it but what we can do is just make it
more manageable and that's what that uh
policy does with regard to
your first question i wouldn't describe
it as a bailout and i think actually
what that was is something very
different we are not providing loans to
energy companies well what we are doing
is discounting people's bills by 200
pounds we're using their energy bill as
a means to do that but in no way shape
or form is this a a bailout of energy
companies it's absolutely not this is
help to families to households just
delivered through their energy bills and
then ultimately recovered through their
energy bills uh in in the future so i
think it's very different to what some
people were were calling for um and i
think it's the right intervention and
many have called for some smoothing
mechanism because when you're faced with
a shock of this magnitude the sensible
thing for governments to do as i said is
not to pretend that it doesn't exist but
to help ease the burden of it by
spreading it over some years um but
thank you thank you all very much that
was hopefully helpful and uh i'll see
you all again soon thank you
there we are rishi sunak outlining the
government help uh being offered to
households about to be hit by a 54
increase in energy bills offering 200
pounds a discount on all electricity
bills later to be repaid though and 150
pounds a council tax rebate for many
households the chancellor was asked
about boris johnson's comments to kia
starmer about jimmy savile
and he said being honest i would not
have said it but he went on to say he's
glad that boris johnson had clarified
the comments and
he said he generally supported boris
johnson's response to the sue gray
report our political editor beth rigby
is in westminster and beth we'll talk
about that in just a minute
um
i suppose on fuel the question is
you know will it be seen as enough help
and the right type of help
well mark there's a lot in that press
conference as you said politically
there's a lot in there which we can come
back to but just on the thing that
probably everyone is worrying about and
thinking about the issue about fuel
bills and the rising uh cost
of living
fuel bills confirmed to rise today by
nearly 700
pounds and the government trying today
to try and take some of the pressure off
households of lots of people uh
struggling
with this uh they are going to take 200
pounds
off everyone's energy bills in october
you then repay that over five years 40
pounds a year which rishi sonak was
saying there he hoped would somehow
amelia ate this ameliorate this big
pressure and then 150 pounds off council
tax
bills for people in bands a uh to d 3.5
billion pounds of government spending in
total 9 billion pounds of government
spending on this but look i think the
key thing there for me listening uh was
when rishi sunat right at the top uh was
asked well come on i mean energy bills
are going to carry on rising aren't they
through the year and next year and he
said yes they are we're going to have to
adjust to this and what we're trying to
do is take a little bit of the pressure
off and and just to put it into contacts
mark i mean families are going to
experience the biggest fall
to earnings since records began in the
early
1990s energy bills going up you've got
those tax rises coming in in april
inflation
expected predicted to rise to 7.25
that's just eye watering really isn't it
uh in april so it's going to be a very
bumpy uh few months for many families
trying to adjust and grapple uh with
these huge rises to their costs of
living and their weekly bills
yeah and just moving on to um
the he was asked about boris johnson's
comments to
um kia stammer about jimmy savile and
which has led today to the resignation
of a senior adviser manure mirza i just
want to show viewers first of all
what manira murza said and then we'll um
hear what uh
rishi sunak said in response but here's
what miss murza said i believe it was
wrong for you to imply this week that
kierstam was personally responsible for
allowing jimmy savile to escape justice
there was no fair or reasonable basis
for that assertion this was not the
usual cut and thrust of politics it was
an inappropriate and partisan reference
to a horrendous case of child sex abuse
you tried to clarify your position today
but despite my urging you did not
apologize for the misleading impression
you gave and uh this is what uh rishi
sunak had to say
first thing to say is you know she was a
valued colleague i very much enjoyed
working with her and i'm sorry to see
her leave government i'll miss working
with her and with regard to their
comments
and you know being being honest i
wouldn't have said it and i'm glad that
the prime minister clarified what he
meant
so beth i mean being honest i wouldn't
have said it
let's unpack pack all of this a bit now
uh uh mineira merza who who you won't
know out there uh but she's a very well
known figure
in number 10 in the heart of boris
johnson's government you can see her on
your screen she's worked with boris
johnson since 2008 on and off she worked
with him
in city hall when he came into number 10
in 2019 he brought her in as his
director of policy she is one of his
closest allies and that is why her
departure today has really sent
shockwaves uh around this place because
quite simply she is one of those people
that you always expected to be by his
side that she has decided to resign
really is here
a big moment and it's now raising
serious questions about what is really
going on
in the hearts of number 10 how much
trouble is boris johnson in one person
suggested me is the dam about to burst
is this going to be the straw that broke
the camel's back look that's all really
unclear now we've been talking about
this haven't we for days letters
dripping in how much trouble is the pm
in but if i just pull up what rishi
sunak said look the reason that that is
politically
really interesting and dangerous for the
prime minister
is because sonic there the chancellor
the would-be successor to him was quite
clearly critical of the prime minister
not explicitly not in a bombastic way
but the fact he said and i was just
pulling it up in my notes here the fact
he said being honest i wouldn't have
said it he wouldn't have made those
remarks that uh boris johnson made about
um jimmy savile in the commons towards
kierstama i wouldn't have said it and
it's good the prime minister clarified
what he meant what the prime minister
didn't do today because he did clarify
the remarks and he did try and say that
he wasn't saying that kirsten was
passing involved in the lack of
prosecution over jimmy savile
but what he didn't do was directly
apologize and that is why uh ms moser
resigned today that she wanted an
apology and then when rishi sunat was
asked three times does he think the
prime minister should apologize he just
kept saying
let me just get it
that's for the prime minister to decide
but i'm glad he's clarified today what
that is in political
reading between the lines is that is the
chancellor just quite simply not back in
the prime minister putting water putting
distance between him and i would say
being quite critical of him so that is
very significant because it suggests
that
we've seen this shock resignation and
now the chancellor publicly saying what
he's saying support is visibly draining
away from the prime minister his
authority uh clearly under threat and
there have been many cabinet ministers
that have come out and defended boris
johnson around everything he said and
anything he said rishi sanat will not be
that person and it's because he has an
eye on the top job and he is now putting
obvious distance between him and his
boss
beth before you go let's just have a
listen to
you what you were talking about there
boris johnson's clarification on all
this
let's be absolutely clear i'm i'm
talking not about uh the leader of the
opposition's personal
um record when he was uh when he was dpp
and i and i totally understand that he
had nothing to do
personally with those decisions i was
making a point
about
um
the his responsibility for the
organization
as a whole and i think people can can
see that i just i really do want to
clarify that because it is it is
important
so that clarification not enough clearly
for manira mersa and just to round this
off beth how much is of a blow is
um her loss
look it's a massive blow because as i
was saying she was one of his closest
allies it was someone that has always
been by his side and when people that
have been that loyal to him for that
long
decide that they simply cannot tolerate
staying on that it's time to part ways
with someone that she has worked with
since 2008 and these are really
demanding jobs you have to be very
committed to it she came back and has
worked in number 10 as i said since he
became
leader of the conservative party and
prime minister in july 2019 for her to
go is a real body blow to the prime
minister but i think also it's the
ripple effect like now we're all asking
around here well what does it really
mean how bad is this
is this as i said the the damn break-in
and that actually
the momentum really is now moving
against boris johnson he can't shore up
his leadership and i don't have the
answer this is the question around here
everyone's asking but it is another
damaging sign for him and then the
pressure is piled on because the
chancellor there is quite clearly saying
i'm my man and he's his man and i'm not
going to try and defend what i am not
comfortable with defending
for the prime minister and that shows a
challenge if you like to his authority
okay beth thank you very much indeed
right this is the newshour coming up
we'll be talking a lot more about the
hike in energy prices
[Music]
you